all right President Trump is standing by
his pledge to brand Republicans the
party of health care but he said he's
delaying any new push for legislation
until after the 2020 elections now the
president said in a speech last night
that the change was of course his
decision but the truth is it came after
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
who runs the Senate he's the boss there
said that the Senate would not revisit
health care before the elections I made
it clear to him and we were not going to
be doing that in the Senate he did say
as he later tweeted he accepted that
well Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
what's behind this apparent Republican
split on health care and Nancy good
morning boy Mitch McConnell has a way of
setting things straight he sure does and
now the president is doing a little
fancy footwork here because Republicans
essentially balked when he started
publicly pushing them to try again on
health care Republicans argued that any
plan that they come up with now is sure
to die in the democratically controlled
house so the president backed down for
now we're going to come up with a health
care plan we're not gonna vote on it the
president Trump laid out part of his
2020 game plan last night bowing to
dominate Democrats on the issue of
health care we have the crime we have
the police we have the military we have
so much they have health care right now
we have to take that away from it the
president said voters will love his
still unwritten plan we're gonna promise
the people that if you vote for us and
if you vote for you all of you running
that we're gonna vote for this it's
gonna happen the president's promises
this week have surprised Republicans and
drawn mockery from Democrats they will
come up with their plan in 2021
translation they have no health care
plan Republicans controlled both houses
of Congress the president's first two
years in office but failed to repeal and
replace Obamacare polls showed health
care was the most important issue to
voters in the 2018 midterm elections
when Republicans lost control of the
House and it's been a hot topic for
Democratic presidential candidates do
not believe
we cannot make healthcare a right for
all people health care should be a right
and not a privilege for all Americans
access to affordable health care should
be a right for all and not a privilege
for those who can afford it a recent
survey found that last year alone
Americans borrowed an estimated eighty
eight billion dollars to pay for health
care costs
one in four skipped treatment because it
was too expensive
the deductibles are so high that nobody
gets to use it unless you're in serious
condition so serious that frankly the
last thing on your mind is healthcare
this all started a week ago when the
Department of Justice at the urging of
the White House took a new position
pushing for the full repeal of Obamacare
in the courts the Republican leader
Mitch McConnell argued that isn't going
to happen anytime soon so his party he
says has a lot of time to come up with a
replacement plan John all right Nancy
thanks so much